I remember seeing a graph for people who
are in
especially for large organizations I
remember seeing a graph that someone
said which was a flat graph the line was
flat and they said this is the new up
you on the other hand and I really want
to bring this home you broke your your
own record right because from a three
billion dollar campaign to a 3.5 billion
you actually brought in 3 point 8
1,000,000,000 that was a remarkable
achievement but it also highlights
something which is about the capacity
that that our donors had to do this and
the capacity that Yale had to manage
those relationships how is that
replicable for other entities in the
country you use the keyword for this and
that's relationships you know what I see
today in philanthropy happening often is
what i would call transactional you know
I know you have money so I come to you
and ask you for a gift and you give me
something then I turn away and go to the
next person that is not what we define
as philanthropy because philanthropy
really is a relationship and it is a
relationship that we set out to
establish in a university to establish
with our donors our alumni for life so
we are not in it for you know just upon
gift and then we draw people we are in
it for you know keeping our alumni
involved with the university and as they
get to know the behind the scenes of the
university you know what are the
struggles what are the priorities what
is the vision what do we want to
accomplish you know they understand that
it takes money and those who have money
you know then voluntarily participate in
and participate in it much more
generously than if you are just asked
for money and you know here we go